okay good evening ladies and gentlemen
and welcome to tonight's planning
committee meeting my name is Peter
Richards and I will be chairing the
meeting this evening some housekeeping
if I made to start with um I'm sure
you've all got mobile phones if you
would please kindly either turn them off
or at the very least are silent
um I appreciate some emergency so you
may want to use it but if you do please
make sure it doesn't disturb the flow of
the meeting we're not expecting there to
be any fire alarms so if one does go off
if you'd kindly follow us out towards
the uh the car park next to the the
windmill Pub we will need to check your
name off our list to make sure you're at
the building safely and then we can send
you on your Merry Little way the meeting
itself is a meeting in public it is not
a public meeting so only people that
have registered to speak will be
permitted to do so at the appropriate
time I will call you forward to one of
the seats in front of us you will notice
we have some new AV Equipment so a very
quick rundown of how it works it is all
set up ready for you to be for you to
use if you press the button on the right
it will go red and you will be live and
you'll be speaking a camera will come to
you at that point so just be aware of
that as soon as you press it off again
obviously it goes off and the cameras
come back over to us I will give you a
30 second warning before your time is
out rather than so we're going to try
something new today rather than me
disturb you and say 30 seconds you'll
hear this noise
and then if you carry on speaking you'll
know that's your 30 seconds
okay everyone okay with that I've got
everyone sort of smiling and I'm sure
it'll be fine it'll be absolutely fine
okay so I think that's all the announces
so let me introduce everyone on the
panel so uh to my far right we have Kira
Keller who is our Community Services
representative to my immediate right is
Amy Shipley who is our solicitor and our
planners are Amy flute and Paul Thompson
with our planning manager to my
immediate left is Dale Barker Dale I
believe you have a statement to make
I do thank you chairman my role tonight
is to provide impartial advice and to
assist members in their decision taking
thank you chair fabulous thanks very
much and just while I think about it on
the AV Equipment you can see whether
microphone is in relation to me
hopefully you can hear me nice and
clearly please make sure that you bring
the microphone down to about mouth level
uh and speak at the microphone it
struggles to pick you up if you're sort
of looking down okay so there we go
right let's dive into the meeting itself
so will you have any apologies for
absence please here yes we have
apologies from councilor Kendall and
councilor Parry fabulous thank you very
much do we have any disclosures of
Interest please councilor Curtis yeah
thank you chair
um
uh reference 20 stroke zero three five
eight five this has come before Town
Council planning on a couple of on three
occasions I do sit on the Town Council
planning committee so I will absent
myself from the discussion on that item
okay thank you very much
just just to make sure we get the right
one uh that is item five which is
reference
2201972 out is that correct
sorry yes yes that's the correct one so
thank you Jeff for that correction thank
you very much any other disclosures
members no okay do we have uh is
everyone okay with the minutes I'll sign
those afterwards if everyone is okay I'm
seeing some nods and waves yet okay
fabulous okay let's get into the actual
application so the first application is
reference 2201 494 very as I'm sure
you'll see in the update sheet um the uh
objections uh or sorry the committee
trigger have been removed so that item
is being delegated so the first item we
will hear tonight is indeed application
number five which is sorry item number
five application reference
2201972 out to lock up garages on
Hodgson Road our presenting officer is
Amy flute Amy over to you thank you
chairman the app the application site
represented by the black dot on the map
is a former garage site within the
defined built up area boundary of
Stratford
outline planning permission is sought
within the area Edge red for two four
bed dwellings including demolition of
existing garages and the Redevelopment
of the existing hard standing with all
matters reserved except for Access which
is to be determined as part of this
application
the indicative site plan on the left was
for the previous five dwelling scheme
which was dismissed at appeal the
proposed indicative site plan can be
seen on the right and this is for
consideration
the indicative layout indicates two
detachable bed dwellings with private
immunity space the existing access of
hodgson's Road
would be utilized and delineated as a
share space for vehicles and pedestrians
parking and turning would be provided to
the south of the site as well as a
pedestrian link to the existing footpath
to the east
this image is looking in a self-eastly
direction from hodgson's Road The View
into the site and its Associated access
can be seen
the image on the left shows the access
road as it curves to the left on the
immediate approach to the garages the
image on the right shows the curve in
the opposite direction if you were to
exit the site
this image is taken within the site
looking in a northwesterly direction the
access road can be seen as can the
relationship of the site with the
neighboring properties that front onto
hodgson's Road
now looking in a north-eastery direction
to the exist the existing garages can be
seen again the relationship of the site
with neighboring properties on Maple
Grove can be seen
the eastern boundary of this site is now
being shown there is an existing
pedestrian footpath which links the site
between hodgson's Road Maple Grove and
Kennett close it runs
just here
and finally this image is taken from the
access looking in a northwesterly
direction as you exit the site towards
hodgson's Road
the principle of housing is accepted in
this location and there have been no
objections from statutory consulties
chairman the recommendation is to Grant
Subject to conditions and notes
contained within the officer report
please also note the update sheet thank
you
Amy thank you very much indeeds let's
call our first Speaker of the evening
who is councilor Jason voytek
good evening and welcome
and you've been here before so I think
you know the drill but you'll have five
minutes I'll ping the noise at 30
seconds to go whenever you're
comfortable and ready to go press the
button on the right and the floor is
yours
thank you the Crux of this planning
application has gone down from 11
parking spaces to eight in similar so
resulting in similar traffic movements
with this planning application compared
to the rejected planning application and
refusal on appeal last year
the developers have ignored the previous
stipulation by Warwickshire County
Council Highway Authority in their last
application and appeal outcomes the
access width must meet a minimum of five
meters wide for the initial seven and a
half meter length in order to be
considered safe as a shared access for
vehicles alongside the other existing
known and regular users
it's still only proposed to be three six
three point six meters wide at the
access point and the only proposal to
minimize the clear conflict between
vehicles and other existing users of it
is to mark an advisory line along a full
length of the access exit off Hodgson
Road
no measurements have been given for the
proposed advisory marked walkway and as
the access is still early proposed to be
3.6 meters in total width it's clear
that space proposed to be used for eight
Vehicles connected with the Properties
Plus any service vehicles coming and
going to the properties alongside the
large number of other regular users on
foot would not be sufficient nor safe
while vehicles are traveling in and out
of the access
the highways Authority previously
objected to a proposal to use this
access stating the intensification of
use arising from the proposal to
repurpose this space to access
Residential Properties as opposed to the
existing situation
would increase the risk of conflict
between vehicles and pedestrians the
particularly along the narrow section of
the entrance and on the bend of the road
on the approach to the development
highways objected for this reason the
only difference in this application is
proposed of eight rather than 11 parking
spaces are permitted for this
development this does not resolve the
risks identified and documented
during the peak hours of 8 A.M to 9am
and 3 P.M to 4pm the access is used by a
large number of parents and children
going to and from the school and the
play park they walk in groups with
several children on bicycles and in push
chairs and children safely come up and
down the walkway unaccompanied where
they cross to the pavement opposite on
the green previously installed by the
council for the safety of children
the audit that was carried out on the
site was not carried out during peak
hours and was carried out during covid
when the school was closed yet the
auditor still noted a near-on collision
with a pedestrian in the access
what should have happened is that an
orbit an audit of use between the hours
of 8 AM and 9 A.M and 3 P.M to 4 pm on a
school day
a resident survey counted over 300 other
users in these time slots in summer and
ice cream van even parked at the
entrance for children coming out onto
the play Park after school
so on the appeal dismissal that occurred
last year I'll just run down the reasons
for the dismissal
a notable increase in traffic movement
on and off the site than for existing
disused garages vehicle movements
associated with dwellings being
different than for garages
material change in the use of the site
incidents in the past cannot be reliably
used
to predict instance in the future
the access is not wide enough for
vehicles to pass waiting and vehicle
reversing causing obstruction on the
highway and causing concerns for Highway
Safety access would not meet the
requirements in manual for streets 2007
of a minimum unobstructed width for
pedestrians of two meters
insufficient space at the junction for a
fire tender to maneuver easily access
exit in ford gear development would be
harmful to highway safety therefore
contrary to cs26
would result in intensification of the
use of the site in the comings and
goings for residents at the dwellings
the only change in relation to the
reason for dismissal in this new
proposal is a minimum minimal reduction
from 11 parking spaces to eight
therefore none of the previous reasons
for dismissal have changed
thank you
happy to take questions
I was just about to press my button for
the first time
thank you very much council foretic
members do we have any questions for our
counselor please councilor Edmond
thank you Mr chairman
uh councilor fortick um is there any
lighting along that access way where the
road is currently off hodgson's way
uh yes there
yes there is there's Street lamps at
different points
anyone else
no in that case cancel 46 thank you very
much for your time and contribution this
evening thank you okay we will move to
points clarification to our officers
does anyone have any questions for our
officers councilor Edmond first please
thank you again
um councilor fortuit mentioned there
were eight spaces looking at that plan
that looks like six to me which is the
right number please
so as part of this purple there are one
two three
there are six how um sorry six parking
spaces for the dwellings which meets
with SPD standards and free per full bed
unit and then they have provided to
visitor parking spaces which on the size
of this scheme is generous that that's
being provided it's not a requirement of
the SPD
councilor Harvey next please two
questions uh what a factual question
or the distance from the road to the
point on the access road to the point
where it is possible for two cars to to
pass
I can do I would just need to quickly
measure it off the plan if that's okay
fine thank you my second question
um
[Music]
Council for Jack mentioned manual for
streets as a basis for an objection
um
the highway Authority seems to have not
objected can you help us to reconcile
those two
I'll just measure off the plan first and
then we'll come to your second point if
that's it
Council Harvey If you turn your
microphone off that'd be great thank you
foreign okay so if I do it to
um the bend where the road
um widens that is approximately 35
meters
yeah so in terms of your question in
relation to manual for streets um my
understanding would be that highways
would have considered that as part of
their assessment of the application
custom Mills next please
thanks Mr chairman um
the width of this uh
access is it you say 3.6
wide this plan is on on at the right
time so at the narrowest point it's 3.5
meters at the access M 3.6 and it widens
as you get into the site to 4.1 4.2 4.5
yeah okay thank you
Council Rock please
thank you chairman
um Council project referred to the
dismissed appeal
um
could you just summarize what the key
differences are I just wanted to be
clear about that because highways seem
to have withdrawn their objection before
but are there any other factors apart
from that which we should be aware of
so the the main difference between the
two proposal is the appeal which was
um sorry the previous scheme that was
dismissed appeal that was for five
dwellings
um whereas this is for two dwellings so
that's the main difference between the
The Proposal
um so we are presuming that the highways
objections
Were Somehow related to that in are we
are they specific on that because the
numbers of dwellings have been reduced
therefore the highways implications are
less than they were is that the
Assumption we're making so I can read to
you um part of the highways comments on
this application if that's helpful
um so in their um comments highway state
um the current application is for a
reduced number of dwellings which will
generate fewer vehicular trips than the
previous planning application the
proposed scheme has been subject to an
independently prepared road safety audit
the findings of which have been reviewed
by the Warwickshire County Council
safety engineering team and found to be
satisfactory the highway Authority has
no objection subject to planning
conditions
cancer admin please
thank you cheers
um this was back towards the lighting
bit that I asked councilor fortick
um do we know if the lights up and down
there are um the LED type which are
sufficiently bright
and actually you may well have answered
this question in terms of what you just
answered which has been reviewed so that
might be the answer
so I've just put an image up of the
access with the existing
um lighting and it would appear that it
looks like an LED light
okay any more for any more
no in that case let's go to debate who
would like to kick us off
councilor Adam first please
okay
um I think broadly speaking
um it's been de-intensified is that a
word it can be no
um sufficiently to my mind I had a
problem with the lighting and the and
the children moving up and down that
road because kids will be kids uh
I don't perhaps have that problem now
with this and they're only being two
properties there it does seem quite
generous in terms of its parking and
space around it I'm not going to make a
proposal just yet but let's see what
others have got to say first
very good uh cancer Mills please
thanks Michelle I was talking to my
phone because I was actually seeing how
wide a fire engine is which is
um
2.3 meters wide and that is 3.6
and that's at 1.3 meters you've got to
say and
I'm just concerned about the safety of
this if it happened to be a fire which
we hope now fire engine went rushing up
there and there's lady a mum walking
along with her buggy I mean how how safe
is that we haven't got any footpaths
either either side so I'm just a bit
concerned about the safety on this one
Mr chairman so I'll see what others
think but um not happy at the moment
thank you understood I'll just draw your
attention to page 25 and the
Warwickshire fire and rescue response
where they have said they have no
objection and they will be it's
sufficient space councilor Harvey please
uh just to respond to that point it made
me think about uh country lanes in my
ward which are of similar width for for
yards and yards and yards and yards not
35 meters
thank you Council servant
thank you Jeff yeah my main concerned is
safety of pedestrians especially at
school times
because there's nowhere to go
and not all drivers are that considerate
thank you councilor Rock please thank
you chairman
um a couple of things that make this
margin in my view first of all it's an
outline so I think there's gonna have to
be very careful design when it comes to
the reserve matter stage because it is
selling closed but that's not what is
before us
one of the things that I notice on page
bottom of page 27
as we can't meet part P of the
development requirements for the SPD for
refuse
uh I've never seen this before that
we're going to rely on some sort of
contract with the private waste
collection service
I am a bit concerned about that I mean
this is all to do with the constricted
axis and the side of it I mean others
have talked about the road width and the
fire service I think I think a warranty
a single Track Road is 3.5 meters so I
think
albeit it's effectively between walls or
between hedges in this case
um again I think that's marginal but um
perhaps I sort of asked this question
the officers but presumably the part
pays to do with the the
circumstances of a pull-out service
being required at some point in the
future and the district council can't
meet that
um
I'm just uneasy about that sort of
situation and what we end up with in
reserve matters
um
that's just a comment chairman I'll
listen to what everyone else has got to
say
okay before we move on someone else I'm
going to ask uh Dale if he would very
kindly give us a sort of a breakdown of
part P of the SPD if you wouldn't mind
please
chair Amy Amy I think he's more in
command of this than I am and she'll
take you through it in just a moment
I'm just trying to find the relevant
part to share with you
foreign
a little bit more so
um the reason
um for the condition for private waste
collection is because of because of the
length of the access the
um access doesn't meet with the
requirements for the carry distance for
residents and um the refuse collectors
for
um
the collection of the refuse on refuse
day because because of its length of its
access so here it says residents should
not have to take their waste and
recycling more than 30 meters to a bin
storage area or take their waste more
than 25 meters to a collection point and
there is another part within this
document which specifies the distances
for the refuse
um
workers as well
thank you chairman so I think we we
learned earlier on that the length of
the carriage of of the access road was I
think 35 meters
plus we'd have a bit more looking at
that plan for the actual dwellings which
depends where they did choose to put the
bin storage so we're talking about 30 as
a rule and we've got about 40 probably
um but we're still looking at for a
private waste collection as part of a
condition then
I think I've got the picture thank you
okay thank you um
Council Forman please
thank you chair I also have concerns
about the access road but
Warwickshire County Council highways
have had no objection and on page 29 of
the report under the fire safety it does
say they do comment that the width is
sufficient for WCC appliances
so I don't have a bit of an issue there
okay I think everyone has pretty much
had a go I'm going to Chuck in my
thoughts now before I call anyone else
in um yes that access road is tight I
think that is accepted by everyone
around the table but the reality is
watch County Council who are The
Authority when it comes to highways have
not provided an objection they did
previously they haven't this time it's
also worth remembering that on the site
are nine garages they can be used at any
time people can come and go and use
those whether they're in use or not now
there is an established use there so
they could be brought back into you some
cars can use that whenever they like
um there is already that conflict
we're talking about two houses with
eight parking spaces in reality two
houses are not going to use those eight
sparking spaces but even if they did
that's less than the nine garages that
could use that access whenever they like
so for me uh on the basis that we have
no objections from the statutory
consultees and knowing that the car
movements can access whenever they want
up and down that driveway I have no
problem in uh going with the officer's
recommendation and I do propose that we
Grant inline with the officer's
recommendation now Council Eden has
signature speaks to council Adam please
thank you chair um I'll second that I
think you're right the template is not
uncommon across the region in terms of
bringing these sites back into use we've
seen long tracks before we saw one in
bidford not that long ago which we
talked a lot about and the bin scenario
was kind of dealt with with that and in
reserve matters we can help nail that
down a bit so 100 second that marvelous
thank you very much Council Rock You
signals just briefly because this is an
outline I'm presuming that we can't say
we only want Bungalows or anything like
that we can't do that that would have to
be a reserve matters if it came for that
I'm concerned about overlooking and so
on eventually
yeah if there is a planning reason you
could condition that
um I would not be inclined to support it
uh given I've already proposed but if
you wanted to give us a a breakdown of
your planning reasons why I'm all ears
where I was thinking of a neighbor
amenity but I'm in two minds about it
because it's gonna it would be
considered Reserve matters so uh
that's another reservation I have but
perhaps I'll take your point chairman I
think perhaps uh we'll let that pass
until it comes to reserve matters
okay does anyone else have anything
they'd like to say in the debate in
which case we'll move forward to a vote
so the proposal is to Grant in line with
the office recommendation uh with
consideration of course to the update
sheet could I please have a show of
hands for those in favor of granting
that's six and those against
that's two and there's no abstentions so
committee therefore resolves to Grant
application
2201972 out the lock-up garages on
Hodgson Road let's move to our final
application of the evening which is
application reference
2201408 ful that is the beaches on
Chapel Street in wellsborn our
presenting officer is Paul Thompson once
Paul is settled and comfortable and
ready to go it's over to him
foreign
[Music]
for this one right in the heart of it uh
in the Conservation Area
uh we've got the river Dean running
across the top right of the sort of the
map there the red buildings are listed
uh there's a very small one just on the
boundary of the site which is a granary
um and then there's obviously others
around uh none of them especially
affected by the proposal
as I set out my report uh this is the
proposal
on the left is the existing dwelling
it's being replaced with a rather larger
version
um
you'll note uh with the same access is
being used and there's a number of uh
back boxes and the like dotted around
this is how the existing dwelling looks
on the ground plans and elevations
um we've gone with the the renders
currently provided by the agent uh for
the proposed dwelling as you can see it
is larger it extends further out to what
would be the rear of the of the dwelling
and is slightly taller a slightly larger
all round
uh this is the photo looking into the
front elevation of the existing dwelling
this uh gives some idea of just how
large the plot is it's uniquely large
and well Wells born in terms of the
relationship between the the developed
portion and the undeveloped
this is the neighboring dwelling a
little smaller but a similar sort of
vintage 1980s design aesthetic
um share my recommendation is to Grant
permission in the meantime I'd like to
draw your attention to the update sheet
uh we have uh award member objection
that's now been withdrawn as of the 18th
of January we also have two additional
conditions for your consideration the
first is uh implementation of tree
protection measures
um the submitted arboricultural impact
assessment does contain some heads of
terms for for that those measures but
we'll need to see sort of site-specific
detail and see them implemented before
work starts uh we'd also like to see a
construction management plan but only
really a fairly simple one just in terms
of working hours really the access is
wide enough to accommodate construction
vehicles and finally a note just to
emphasize that we'd expect the landscape
scheme under what will be condition six
assuming those conditions are accepted
should include some trees to replace
those that have failed prior to the
application as I say chair my
recommendation is to Grant permission
Paul thank you very much indeed right
let's call our first speaker on this
item who's counselor and Pryor of
wellsborn and Walton Parish Council
good evening councilor Pryor and welcome
are you again are you've been here
before so I think you know the journal
but you'll have three minutes I'll press
the button the 30 seconds when you're
settled and comfortable the floor is
yours
okay the parish council objects to this
development
um because of its increase in size
contrary to what the planning office has
just said it's not slight it's doubling
it's going from 215 square meters to 478
square meters that's a doubling of the
size of the building
and the parish council
um considers that this is something is
over development to the site
had the building been within the current
footprint the council might have been
minded to agree to the development this
was our objection in the initial
application and our view had not changed
when the amended plans came out for
consultation in November
the site is in the conservation area of
the village and the development was
secluded a little down the access track
would nonetheless impact upon the local
character of the area
this side of Chapel Street is subject to
flooding from the dean quite significant
flooding in previous years and we
believe that a development of this scale
could add to that risk as the land
available to absorb water whether from
the dean or rainfall is decreased
significantly
the planning officer states that this
build a replacement dwelling increases
its benefit to the district of providing
one single self-build dwelling we do not
think that that is a valid planning
reason to include in recommending this
development we as a counselor not here
to necessarily Meet The District's
requirement to the detriment of the
local area
we ask that you refuse this development
on the grounds we've indicated and asked
the applicant to propose a dwelling of a
size in keeping with the current house
and which significantly adds to the
diversity of housing in the village and
offers real sustainability features
thank you
thank you very much indeed members do we
have any questions for councilor Pryor
please Council Rock
I'll be asking the officer this question
but um I've been reading your Naval
development plan
ww9
uh and uh it talks about that um
properties should be in keeping with
surrounding properties
could you tell us anything about the
surrounding properties for those of us
that are not deeply knowledgeable about
the detail of this area
send it off yeah sorry about that
um as it was shown on the original map
there are some listed buildings in the
area the buildings generally round about
it are brick built and further down the
road they're our buildings which have
white faces on them then none of them as
large as this we have some very linear
buildings in the village because they're
old and that was the way they were built
so rather than you know the long line so
the parish council feels it actually
doesn't fit in with what is there
currently with a lot of small Cottages
down that road Terrace Cottages as well
and it's a very narrow Access Road
Chapel Street itself with parking on
both sides and difficult access down the
access alley towards this building at
the back
thank you any other questions for our
Our member sorry our parish council
member no council price thank you very
much your time contribution this evening
okay let's call our last speaker on this
item who and I've could have been down
here as either Michael or Mark mcternan
is that correct
who have we got is this Michael or Mark
that's absolutely fine no problem at all
um
yeah I was about to ask you to lift the
microphone but you're already on it well
done you okay so um whenever you're
ready and comfortable if you press the
button on the right you'll have three
minutes I'll press the button when
you've got a 30 second it would be I
don't you think you were here when I
pressed it before so just so you know
that
um when you're ready feel free to start
the new replacement dwelling has been
upgraded from a householder's extension
at an alterations plan application for a
full replacement house planner
application also supported by both
planning Authority officers the
replacement house has a high quality
distinctive design of character and
complies with the Stratford on AU from
District Council residential design
guidelines
there is no impact on neighborhood
amenities this will be respected during
the construction period and indeed the
application has been well supported by
the main adjoining neighbors with
supportive letters all welcoming the
applicants and their proposals
the replacement house mainly sits on the
same footprint as the original house
with areas added for the kitchen lounge
and enclosed pool a widened garage and
drive to accommodate modern day cars
that will enable safe and easy turning
and driving out of the site that the
existing restrictive Drive does not
allow
the application site is set well back
behind the Chapel Street Frontage and
cannot be seen from the Main Street and
will not impact on the conservation area
with that in mind the house is designed
for modern day living whilst including
traditional features to serve and
enhance the conservation area all due
care will be taken with nearby existing
trees
the replacement house will sit
comfortably in a generous Site Area with
the replacement house occupying less
than 20 site coverage of the main site
area this does not include the shared
Drive which reduces coverage even more
the replacement house we supported would
also be supported on all energy and
ecology aspects the sustainability and
renewable energy installations will be
included within the replacement dwelling
design
the new build construction is designed
to Modern sustainable low-carb and
design standards and will incorporate
Energy Efficiency heating lighting
ventilation systems and will have high
insulation standards that will help
reduce energy demand the replacement
house will also have a raised ground
floor that will reduce any risk of flood
and impact of climate change is also
taken into account with the within the
design
the replacement design will also look to
utilize rainwater harvesting and will
utilize the existing main foul drainage
via the shear drive and they're into
Chapel streets the replacement house
heating will include a low carbon
renewable energy ground Source heat pump
design and solar panels on the south
facing roof areas to the rear of the new
property Batten out boxes are also to be
incorporated recommended by the
ecologists and the applicant will also
be keeping beehives and is Keen to
incorporate wildflowers a landscaping of
semi-rature trees and plants native to
the South Warwickshire area we use the
applicant's agents have taken on board
all comments raised within the planning
consultations process to come up with a
pleasing design to meet the planning
Authority's requirements and clients
brief
thank you thank you fabulous within your
time and I even got a chance to use my
new button so thank you
members do we have any questions for
either of our guests here
no
in that case Michael marks thank you
very much for your time contribution
this evening
okay let's move to punch clarification
to our offices members do we have any
points to be clarified councilor Harvey
first please
um thank you Mr chairman um would the
officer be prepared to accept a
compliment on the presentation he's made
in his paper which I found almost
enjoyable to read
particularly particularly it's Pages 36
and 37 where he succinctly explained the
interrelationship with on self-build and
custom build between nppf and the core
strategy I found that particularly
helpful
anymore and I'll have to give him a pay
rise please stop
all right let's get focused back on
business thank you very much councilor
Harvey we are of course looking to ask
questions now so councilor Eden first
please
um the existing property pool is this
is it a does it have permitted
development rights as it stands
uh it does counselor yeah thank you
councilor Mills please
thanks Mr chair and Paul um
I'm just trying to look at that I'm
looking at the plan here and on there
the nearest neighbor how close is newest
neighbor to this um
to the proposed development
all right
um
so the uh the elevations in question do
comply with our SPD standards in terms
of distances from walls and so forth I
think perhaps more importantly there are
no facing windows and particularly with
the um the northernmost uh segment the
um
boundary shared with Willow Dean to the
north uh West there that's almost
entirely single story that part
um so my view is there's going to be no
impact on daylight there's no facing
Windows to cause a privacy concern
foreign
silly question but this is the only
house on this development isn't it
there's nothing else is there uh
um the agent spoke about a shared drive
and I couldn't quite understand that yes
that's that's the property I was
referring to so it's Willow Dean it's
just immediately to the north west and
that's that's it was built around the
same time
um to the best of my knowledge
um
and it's the shed it shares that drive
and there is also a dwelling that is on
this on the street proper if you like
um which kind of shares that drive I
suppose but it's yeah the frontage is on
the street
Mr Mustang whilst I applaud Your
Enthusiasm to continue to be sat with us
um I am going to have to ask you to make
your way towards the back and sit in the
uh in the gallery thank you uh Council
Rock next please uh thank you chairman
um
again I I I've made a mistake of
swatting up on the naval development
plan but um
this is you you comment on page 38 that
it's much larger than its predecessor
going from 215 to 478 is it possible to
show us pictures of the house it's been
replaced in comparison with the one that
we would get now if we were married to
approve this and the 478 meters what
what does that include how does that
calculation work some of the you know
from what I remember the pictures we
have a significant single floor element
of this uh
what does that contain I'm interested in
weighing up the total size of this
dwelling compared
with what's written in the naval
development plan
uh so I think this is probably the best
plan I can show you
um in terms of comparison if I scroll
back through forgive me floating through
like that so that's that's what's there
at the moment so we have the similar
sort of L-shaped plan
um with a with a second story element on
the on the main under the main Ridge
line
now the main difference with the new
plan is is the swimming pool which you
can see at the top of the uh floor plan
there that's all single story that's
that's this element
on the elevations
so that's all single story
um the main Ridge line
visible mostly on on these elevations is
increasing in height one point by 1.5
meters the eaves are going up by about
1.4 meters
um but it Remains the case that most of
the additional floor area I would say is
at ground floor level it's the swimming
pool fundamentally and and a little uh
sort of here if you can see where my
mouse pointer is
uh sort of that that element is going to
project further back into the site
cancer Curtis please
microphone please counselor Curtis
um
sorry Paul can you just confirm I don't
think there were any objections from the
immediate neighbors is that correct on
the contrary there were three letters of
support right from your neighbors which
is unusual right thank you
okay any more for any more cancer Rock
again
um I notice on uh
hang on a moment uh the page 43
seal payments
you say it will generate a civil
liability of 20
723 pounds this is a self build isn't it
is that not still exempt indeed and it
would be yes
so is that probably should have
mentioned that in the report really
shouldn't uh
so so it hasn't it hasn't got a still
reliability uh not as it stands they
would have to claim the self-build
extension exemption excuse me
um which they can't yet they've
indicated is on the um the sill form
um but that would obviously
evidence-based right okay thank you
chairman I wonder if councilor Harvey
wants to
bring back his comments earlier about
the quality of Europe no he doesn't know
okay
um
all right I'm gonna assume there are no
more points that need clarifying for
members given I've seen no more hands go
up so let's move our way into the debate
who would like to kick us off in the
debate councilor Eden please
uh thank you chair
um
yeah it's undoubtedly a large extension
or self-build effectively on on a
similar footprint
um
but it does seem in a very generous plot
it does seem like the proposal is well
screened and my problem here is that I
can't really see the over development is
particularly defensible
um on its own it probably needs
something else to stand up in front of
an inspect an an inspector put my teeth
back in
um I think I'm going to propose that we
go with officer's recommendation on this
you think you are or you are oh shout
good man thank you very much Council
Mills please yeah thanks Mr chairman
yeah I mean it's um it does look and
sound like a very nice house a good all
the green credentials with it as well
um I did see there are no objections
from the neighbors uh or in fact three
letters of support
um
yes Miss Jim I'm quite happy to uh
second uh councilor Eden's proposal
thank you Mr chair fabulous thank you
very much anyone at councilor Rock
please I thank you chairman uh well I I
have swung backwards and forward during
the discussion here this evening uh the
thing I'm very keen in I should probably
gather these honoring Naval development
plans in this one in particular uh and
uh on the basis of the report
um and what was written before I
actually saw the detail of design
uh I I did wonder about its conformance
with the naval development plan in view
of the answers we've been given
fundamentally the the big increase in
size would appear to uh the officers
told us this is the is the single story
extension to accommodate the uh the pool
so uh
orbits in a Conservation Area it's a
much larger larger building it seems a
very attractive design
um I I think I would go along with the
with the proposal that has been made
um uh albeit the naval development plan
does suggest it shouldn't be such a
large extension but it's not quite the
house is it it's not quite the living
space it's the uh it's it's that single
story extension which seems to very
nicely done so uh
I think I'm going to go along with the
recommendation
just to point out that you've referred
to extensions there quite a lot this
isn't an extension that's being applied
for it is a complete rebuild so the yeah
it's worth a sloppy use of language Mr
chairman I you are absolutely right from
your good self okay I think we uh are
pretty much done in debate now unless
anyone is desperate to speak no in that
case um I'm just going to check Council
Redden your proposal is in line with the
office of recommendation including the
two additional conditions and the note
that's been put in the update sheet yes
chair councilman's just confirmed that
you're happy I hope that Mr chairman
being marvelous on that basis then could
I please have a show of hands for those
in favor of granting
that is unanimous so committee therefore
resolves to Grant application 220140 ful
and the beaches in wellsborn
um I believe there's no urgent business
in that case thank you very much members
officers and members of the public and
we'll see you next